[Music]
reinvention to me means the ability for
our country and its people to be able to
imagine a better future for ourselves I
am the child of two South Indian
immigrants and India is a place that is
my second home that I love so so dear
and it is a place that is already being
ravaged by the climate crisis whether
it's people warring over access to water
or people not having adequate resources
like good food to eat or or clean air to
breathe we have grown up our entire
lives knowing that the climate crisis
was a problem and watching people who
were generations above us watching our
politicians kick the can down the road
and fail to act
sunrise movement is building a movement
of young people to stop the climate
crisis and create millions of good jobs
for our generation the climate crisis is
immense it's terrifying and then also
having to guide this movement that we
hope to grow to millions of people is
also innocence and terrifying in just a
totally different way so it's really
important for me to wake up in the
morning and get really grounded I
meditate I spend time journaling I spend
time just alone with my thoughts and
exercising I spend time just grounding
myself so that when I go out in the
world and I have to whatever it might be
have a management call with somebody on
my team or whether it's guiding our team
through a strategic conversation or I'm
out rallying people at public events
like I do all the time that I am my most
compassionate stable and grounded leader
that I possibly can be I think
ultimately what this comes down to is
how much power does our generation have
and by power I mean how much influence
over the course of events the course of
history in this country do young people
in this nation have and I think for me
we can't stop until we build the level
of power that we need as a generation to
make our policy holders listen to us
[Music]
you